en mai dernier le festival nuits
d'afrique de montréal a présenté la
programmation de sa 32e édition sous
l'oeil attentif de celui qu'il a fondé
lamine touré pour les artistes
puis vient de l'afrique aux caraïbes
on est le premier verre découvrir à
montréal on est le premier ce guinéen
d'origine arrivé à montréal en 1974 et
celui qui a introduit la musique
africaine à montréal il ouvre en août
1986 le légendaire bar balaient tout sur
la rue saint-laurent
comme j'ai fait balade où j'ai appel
balle à tous bâle pour tout le moins
c'est chabal à dos puis il fonde dans la
foulée le festival nuits d'afrique qui a
fait venir à montréal des grands noms de
la musique africaine
papa wemba manu dibango salif keita
angélique kidjo mélamine touré a aussi
fait découvrir des artistes africains et
des artistes québécois d'origine
africaine ou caribéenne comme zale
sissoko et gélita pas je peux dire que
je suis un enfant un artiste n'est pas
retour est né au balattou néo nuits
d'afrique grandiose nuits d'afrique
c'est d'être prêt précise qu'il nous
apporte pour nous faire connaître au
niveau du canada et hors du canada aussi
rassembleur humaniste un monument les
qualificatifs ne manquent pas pour
décrire lamine touré également surnommé
le baobab de montréal qui tôt fait de la
peur qu'il a apportée l'afrique avec lui
ce grand continent a apporté à la
régulière ici à montréal parce que la
démarche depuis le début se faire
connaître l'afrique je dirais plutôt
qu'il a installée l'afrique à montréal
au canada en amérique du nord
il n'a cessé quand même mardi qu'il a
planté qui est en train de qui grandit
et qui pousse encore répit qui fait
encore plein de branches partout partout
c'est un visionnaire tour et c'est comme
un vieux sage africain
c'est une richesse culturelle est finie
tous les jours j'apprends quelque chose
avec monsieur touré lamine touré
projette maintenant de lancer un
festival en afrique dans plusieurs pays
francophones la guinée burkina mali
sénégal côte d'ivoire pour qu'hommage
est vrai macho mon rêve serait de la
mine touristes cherchent activement un
partenaire fiable en afrique pour
réaliser ce rêve
et si catherine françois radio canada
montréal
[Musique]